bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur les
plateformes du figaro ces figures alive
on attend d'un instant à l'autre
maintenant
l'annnonce du nouveau gouvernement
l'annnonce de l'équipe castex c'est à
vivre en direct sur le site du figaro
c'est à vivre en direct sur figaro live
en attendant on attend vos points de vue
comme confrontera avec ce soir ceux de
carl meeus bonsoir rédacteur en chef au
figaro magazine
avec ceux de sylvie bommel biographe
grand reporter notamment à vanity fair
bonsoir sylvie avec ceux d'olivier
babeau écrivain essayiste et président
de l'institut sa pièce bonsoir olivier
et alexis poulain cofondateur du média
en ligne
le monde moderne karl sylvie ollivier
alexis et vous qui nous regardent et en
attendant le remaniement je vous propose
de revenir à bien sûr les premières
heures les premiers pas de jean castex
vous ont-ils convaincu
et puis on reviendra également sur ce
qui attend le gouvernement sur sa
feuille de route qu'elle doit être
cette feuille de route sur ces sujets
sylvie carle olivier alexis et vous qui
nous regardent et j'attends bien entendu
vos commentaires vos analyses vos points
de vue
la droite et la gauche sont mécontents
macron a donc visé juste je lui dis
bravo
c'est le commentaire votre commentaire
been internautes du figaro sur les
premiers pas du nouveau premier ministre
alors le nouveau premier ministre ne
vous a pas répondu mais il a répondu à
ceux qui ne voient en lui qu'un fantôme
un personnage falot ou un vulgaire
collaborateurs d'emmanuel macron quand
vous aurez appris à me connaître vous
verrez que ma personnalité n'est pas
soluble dans le terme de collaborateurs
c'est ce que déclare jean castex hier au
journal du dimanche
pourtant pourtant on s'était posé la
question en l'écoutant vendredi sur le
plateau de tf
soyons clairs madame je ne suis pas ici
pour chercher la lumière
je suis ici pour chercher des résultats
résultat de l'action publique
énergique dans le cadre d'un plan de
relance vigoureux que nous préparons
pour reconstruire notre pays
ici pour chercher la lumière disait jean
castex pour je ne suis pas ici pour
chercher la lumière c'est ce que dit
donc jean castex pourtant les caméras
étaient nombreuses pour le suivre ce
week end à corbeil essonnes dans l usine
de semi-conducteurs x fab et hier soir à
la courneuve pour une visite surprise
dans un commissariat de
seine-saint-denis et ces questions et là
je poserai également une question à
carlo note déjà des recadrages par le
président que ce soit d'abord la date du
discours de politique générale où les
messages des manuels macron sur les
réseaux sociaux sur ce que doit être la
ligne du gouvernement
voilà ok parfait weh césar c'est pour ça
que je vois là et après ces questions
les premiers pas de gens tac castex en
tant que premier ministre vous ont-ils
convaincu c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter et vous êtes une légère
majorité à répondre non en début
d'émission des interventions
d'internautes suivent ensuite on
commence avec le off est ensuite le
commentaire de l'internaute
la composition de mon équipe
correspondra aux priorités que nous nous
fixons ce n'est pas d'abord un casting
c'est un choix politique et cela doit
répondre à une exigence de compétences
ce qui m'importe c'est l'opérationnalité
trouve s'entraîner elle dira c'est loupé
rocio l'opérationnalité
l'opérationnalité ça c'est pas du
langage techno l'opérationnalité des
ministres être capable du conte viennent
d'entrer en action tout de suite voilà
l'objectif de jean castex l'objectif
affiché encore une fois dans son
interview au journal du dimanche le site
du figaro
vous n'êtes pas tous convaincus un
internaute qui se fait appeler rebelles
estiment lui castex sert de vitrine à
jupiter qui continuera à tenir les fils
hal à les ficelles changement de casting
n'est pas changement de politique
et c est la question twitter qu'elle
devrait être le chantier prioritaire
pour le nouvel de nouveau gouvernement
d'après vous l'écologie la sécurité où
l'économie alors tout à l'heure c'était
l'économie qui arrivait en tête
et bien c'est toujours l'économie qui
arrive en tête n'en sait là c'est
désormais la sécurité mais vraiment pas
l'écologie
excellent et parfait je les salue
bonsoir alexis bonsoir olivier bonsoir
s'il lit
alors on aura est ce que je sais pas si
vous m'entendez
olivier alexis sylvie normalement on
annonce le nouveau gouvernement à partir
de 17h donc peut-être aurons-nous le
plaisir d'avoir monsieur colère sur le
perron de l'elysée sinon
on essaiera d'obtenir jusqu'à 17h45 et
puis
on rendre à l'antenne comme on dit en
télé sinon de ce troisième positon
troisième possibilité c'est d'ici 17h45
qui est l'annoncent
et est ce que on peut compter sur vous
pour un débrief juste après le temps
qu'ils le fassent
le temps qu'il le fasse si vous comptez
une dizaine de minutes après le 10
minutes après la après l'annonce quoi
comment partir à 18 heures avec 6,6 lui
c'est bon olivier c'est bon ok on à karl
qui hélas arrivé là on entend les gros
mots
oui tout le monde entend
ce sens
à la honte entend bien jean charles mais
bonjour
car longtemps tant la honte en temps on
ne te voit pas il ya un écho terrible
là je vois là sa lucarne
mais pas mais pas au niveau de la
réalisation tu as tu es à côté de moi tu
as ma gauche comme à droite je sais plus
à ma droite quand je suis tué à gauche
en face je suis interdit de tuer ma
droite
on
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur la les
plateformes du figaro c'est figaro live
on attend d'un instant à l'autre bien
sûr l'annnonce du remaniement l'annnonce
du loup gouverne du nouveau gouvernement
alors ce sera à vivre en direct bien sûr
sur le site du figaro ce sera à vivre en
direct sur figaro live mais en attendant
on attend vos points de vue qu'on va
confronter ce soir avec ceux de carl
meeus
bonsoir karl rédacteur en chef au figaro
magazine
on va les confronter aussi avec ceux de
sylvie bommel biographe grand reporter
notamment à vanity fair bonsoir syli
prochain d'olivier babeau écrivain
essayiste et président de l'institut
sapiens et ce d'alexis poulain
cofondateur du média en ligne
le monde moderne bonsoir alexis alors
avec joue alexis avec vous olivier avec
vous car le avec vous s'il vit est avec
vous qui nous a regardés en attendant le
remaniement je vous propose de revenir
d'abord sur les premiers pas de jean
castex depuis sa nomination
vendredi dernier nomination que vous
avez pu vivre en direct ici même sur ce
plateau en tous les cas sur le site du
figaro et sur la feuille de route du
futur gouvernement on peut spéculer sur
le sur le casting mais surtout ce qui
importe c'est ce qui attend ce nouveau
gouvernement à ce qu'il pourra faire ce
qu'il doit faire selon vous en tout cas
eh bien on en débat sur ces sujets carl
olivier sylvie et alexis et vous qui
nous regardent et j'attends bien entendu
vos commentaires vos analyses vos avis
vos points de vue
alors sur le site du figaro vous êtes
assez sévère sur la nomination de jean
castex en tout cas un certain nombre
d'entre vous on vous pose d'ailleurs la
question ce soir sur twitter
mais par exemple il ya ce commentaire la
droite et la gauche sont mécontents
macron a donc visé juste je lui dis
bravo c'est le commentaire de binh un
internaute du figaro sur les premiers
pas du nouveau premier ministre
alors le nouveau premier ministre bis ne
vous a pas répondu directement mais il a
répondu à ceux qui le prennent pour un
personnage falot pour ceux qui le
prennent pour un simple technocrates un
simple factotum un vulgaire
collaborateurs des banales macron quand
vous aurez appris à me connaître vous
verrez que ma personnalité n'est pas
soluble dans le terme de collaborateurs
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré donc hier au
journal du dimanche pourtant s'était
posé la question c'est vrai en
l'écoutant notamment vendredi soir sur
le plateau de tf1
soyons clairs madame je ne suis pas ici
pour chercher la lumière
je suis ici pour chercher des résultats
résultat de l'action publique
énergique dans le cadre d'un plan de
relance rigoureux que nous préparons
pour reconstruire notre pays
alors je ne suis pas ici pour chercher
la lumière c'est ce que vient de dire ce
qu'on vient d'entendre de la part de
jean castex pourtant les caméras étaient
nombreuses pour le suivre ce week end à
corbeil essonnes dans l' usine de semi
conducteurs x fab et hier soir dans un
commissariat de seine-saint-denis à la
grève lors d'une visite surprise
sylvie beau mâle vous êtes séduit tout
vous êtes critique
écoutez pour l'instant jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce que quand même on laisse un tout
petit peu travaillé je trouve que il a
réussi les premiers pas puisque
je trouvais que la passation de pouvoir
entre lui et manuel philippe était quand
même vraiment de haute tenue et c'est
pas toujours le cas
au delà des palabres habituel des deux
côtés d'ailleurs de la part de edouard
philippe comme delà du sien lui il a
réussi
enfin il était à la fois la mire réglée
dès pas spécialement effacés moi je
chantais pas quelqu'un qui s'est excusée
d'être là il a dit une chose que j'ai
remarqué que j'ai trouvé assez
intéressante qui était que je sais
puisque que deux parmi les valeurs
qu'ils avaient en commun avec edouard
philippe le service général de l'état
qui prévaut sur toute autre
considération
et quelque part je trouve qu'en faisant
ça y est ils transforment ce qu'on lui
reproche un handicap de deux partenaires
à aucun parti se posaient d'ailleurs que
ce soit vraiment une condition pour être
premier ministre mais bon en un avantage
c'est à dire que je crois que les
défenses ont en tête un petit peu marre
de ces opinions totalement partisane qui
sont dictées vraiment par le parti
auquel on appartient
et voilà donc si réussi à faire ça se
placer au dessus des partis et à être
gaulliste social qui se moquent ils
emploient beaucoup c'était d'avoir une
espèce d'idée comme ça d'être au service
de l'état ce serait pas mal et puis en
amour en comment je trouve que les deux
premières visites qui fait avant même
d'avoir composé son gouvernement avant
même d'avoir un ministre de l'intérieur
dans deux endroits une entreprise une
pme je crois
d'électronique et puis un commissariat
s'est assez bien vu quand même parce que
là on est sur deux priorités l'économie
et puis l'autorité de l'état parce que
là il l'a dit aussi à l'autorité de
l'état c'est un truc important pour lui
a passé un truc c'est bien plus qu'un
truc et je crois que c'est important
aussi pour beaucoup de français après
les mois et les années qu'on vient de
vivre
bon donc j'en déduis que vous êtes pour
répondre à la question vous êtes plutôt
séduite
la date du discours de politique
générale qui a finalement été déjà
reporté les messages des manuels macron
sur les réseaux sociaux sur le sens de
ce que doit faire ce gouvernement car l'
on note quand même déjà des recadrages
par le président de la république
regardera je vous y allez fort disons
que chacun essaye de marquer son
territoire et d'ailleurs il ya du retard
dans l'annoncé de la composition du
gouvernement
et si je comprends bien c'est qu'il ya
des discussions serrées entre l'elysée
et matignon
notamment pour le nom du titulaire de la
place beauvau donc on voit bien que ce
qu'on pensait est très simple al'annonce
de la nomination de jean castex suivi
tout de suite par l' annonce de son
directeur de cabinet qui a été nicolas
revel celui que emmanuel macron avait
voulu imposer à edouard philippe en 2017
et qui n'avait pas pu faire
on s'était dit bon ben voilà ça va être
un simple exécutant il ya l'oeil
j'allais dire l'oeil de moscou l'oeil de
l'elysée à matignon et au fond il va
jean castex va exécuter les décisions
prises à l'elysée
est ce qu'on voit depuis ce week-end
c'est qu'en fait on a un jean castex
pour rejoindre ce que vous avez dit
juste avant qu'il veut imprimer sa
marque
c'est à dire qui fait des visites sur le
terrain qui impriment un tempo assez
rapide
alors même que son gouvernement n'est
pas constitué que qu'il est en train
d'être constitué d'ailleurs on a des
images cet après midi qui sont assez
saisissante puisqu'au fond on imagine
normalement un premier ministre qui doit
être enfermé dans son bureau en train de
passer des coups de fil de discuter pour
faire venir x ou y
et au lieu de ça on a un premier
ministre qui en sortant de l'église
et il va voir le président du sénat
ensuite voir le président de l'assemblée
nationale puis le président du cese et
et de coûts ne donne pas l'impression de
participer à la composition du
gouvernement
donc c'est intéressant de voir que dès
le début il y a
chacun marque son territoire et que ce
soit jean castex par ses déplacements et
que ce soit est mêlé le maquereau par
ses droïdes
alors il ya des discussions serrées vous
nous dites notamment sion le nom du
titulaire de la place beauvau chacun a
imprimé sa marque précisément la visite
dans une usine la volonté d'enrayer la
crise sociale et économique
c'est ce qui l'a en tout le cas déclarés
dès vendredi soir ça doit vous plaire
olivier babeau oui j'ai trouvé que les
deux angles qui était imprimé par la
première les premières visites étaient
très intéressants évidemment le on a
parlé du commissariat et la kz2 l'ordre
je prends était une
rappel important encore plus évidemment
compte tenu du drame de sept gendarmes
si je ne me trompe pas où policiers et
gendarmes qui a été tué tout récemment
évidemment ça s'imposait et j'ai trouvé
très intéressant le fait que le premier
ministre aille dans une industrie
alors pour l'instant les déclarations
étaient évidemment un petit peu général
mais on sait bien que les problèmes de
l'industrie en france dont la part dans
le pib a été divisé par deux en l'espace
de 20 ans ces problèmes ils sont trois
heures c'est un problème de
positionnement depuis longtemps on n'a
pas en fait des coûts du travail qui
sont tellement supérieurs à ceux de
l'allemagne mais l'allemagne a un
positionnement haut de gamme qui fait
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout le même type de
prix et donc ils n'ont pas le même nom
le problème de positionnement
stratégique et donc ils peuvent vendre
beaucoup plus facilement et nous on
n'avait pas ce positionnement ce qui
fait que l'on sait larges ont
désindustrialisé le deuxième problème
c'est un problème lié à la disponibilité
des compétences à l'industrie c'est plus
du tout les temps modernes de charlot ce
sont en fait c'est un endroit où il ya
beaucoup de machines où il ya des gens
avec une compétence assez élevé où les
salaires en fait d'ailleurs sont plus
élevés que dans le reste de l'économie
en moyenne est donc tout ça ça ne
nécessite des compétences et un système
de formation qui marche bien et puis la
troisième chose c'est la chose
fondamentale c'est le problème fiscal ce
sont ces fameuses taxes de production
qui vont s'appliquer avant la prise en
charge a prise en compte des coûts et
qui sont une absurdité échos
mais on a beaucoup de mal à les
supprimer on est environ 50 à 70
milliards de plus par rapport à
l'allemagne de taxes de production sur
notre industrie donc ce qu'il a fait
mourir tout simplement le problème c'est
que sa fille dans nos collectivités
locales comme pour la taxe d'habitation
si vous essayez de supprimer vous vous
heurtez aux problèmes puisque tout est
imbriqué au problème du financement des
collectivités locales donc ça va pas
être très facile on a fait longtemps tu
me dis qu'il faut absolument les
supprimer qu'on leur connaît mais ça va
être la clé de la réindustrialisation en
tout cas c'était une bonne chose de
montrer une bonne volonté de ce point de
vue là mais il va falloir comme toujours
le diable en espagne dans les détails et
dans l'application
alors alors déjà eu en tout cas voulu
adresser une belle feuille de route pour
la réindustrialisation pour le cap vers
la radio cette réalisation il reviendra
sont dans une deuxième partie
en attendant jeu avant de donner de la
parole alexis je salue relents jean
baptiste spitz florentin flight qui nous
ont rejoints sur le chat du figaro
bonsoir à vous merci de vos commentaires
va voulait on va les donner dans un
instant je salue le doris également sur
facebook
jean baptiste qui nous dit si je devais
lui donner un bon point ce serait le
seul que j'ai vu réagir à la mort de
sept gendarmes tués
dans le l'autre sept gendarmes
effectivement qui a été tué lors d'un
contrôle d'un contrôle ce week end et
et donc dont vous pouvez d'ailleurs lire
le portrait sur le site du figaro alexis
poulain j'ajoute également la visite
surprise à la courneuve
ça traduit en tout cas de signe la
volonté d'une reprise en main d'un
retour de l'autorité n'ont pas forcément
autour d'une autorité mais une reprise
en main du ministère de l'intérieur
clairement et puis une écoute des
policiers qui sont très en colère depuis
les dernières déclarations de christophe
castaner et qui n'ont jamais vraiment
travaillé syndicats et ministres main
dans la main depuis que christophe
questionnaire est en poste à ce mystère
donc je crois qu'il ya malaise dans la
police est palpable au delà des nombreux
suicides au delà de problème ça de
désaffection avec les populations là la
façon dont a été gérée la la crise des
gilet jaune puis les enquête de l'igpn
sur les potentielles violences
policières et il est temps effectivement
que ce ministère est bien ce redevienne
régalien se réorganise parce que la
police nationale c'est une institution
essentielle pour la conduite des
activités de l'état et aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'elle est en train de partir
dans tous les sens donc ses premières
visites elle est évidemment importante
pour les policiers mais elle peut aussi
vouloir dire que dès à présent jean
castex prépare en fait les troupes à une
rentrée sociale extrêmement agitée parce
que la crise économique est devant nous
avec ce confinement qui vont te faire
beaucoup points de pib de croissance et
il se pourrait que au delà des plans
sociaux
on est à la fois après le ségur de la
santé et d'autres des pans entiers de la
société qui se retrouve à nouveau dans
la rue
donc on peut craindre est d'ailleurs une
note interne des renseignements craint
une rentrée extrêmement difficile et
délicate donc peut-être que jean castex
mars eux sur des oeufs qu'il est là en
train de préparer déjà les troupes à une
rentrée extrêmement difficile parce que
qu'on veut continuer ses réformes
alors qu'il faudrait peut-être c'est
bien organisé la reprise économique
d'une autre façon que par ces réformes
qui sont celles soit de l'assurance
chômage soit de la retraite ce n'est
peut-être pas mis le moment ni le lieu
compte tenu de la perte de points de
croissance du pays
alors vous pose la question sur twitter
est ce que vous êtes les premiers pas de
jean castex pardon en tant que premier
ministre vous ont-ils convaincu avant
que cette émission ne commence il y
avait une légère majorité pour le nom il
ya toujours une légère majorité pour le
nom bien dites nous pourquoi je salue
notamment les fidèles internautes du
figaro live qui nous rejoignent en cours
de débat nicole citoyens payeurs en
regardant sur la question que vous posez
mais en deuxième partie sur l'écologie
citoyens payeurs et puis également
babineau alors babineau des habitudes
vous êtes plutôt favorable aux emmanuel
macron et au gouvernement donc qu'est ce
que vous pensez justement des premiers
pas de jean castex ce serait intéressant
d'avoir votre avis en attendant je
voudrais qu'on répondre à une question
qui a été posée par spitz et que vous
avez abordé
alexis la dic castex va-t-elle vraiment
stopper la troisième vague sociale votre
avis sur la question c'est lui je ne
sais pas ce que je crois c'est que dans
les changements qui peuvent apparaître
là c'est que probablement pas sur le
fond effectivement et la diva penser que
le dossier des retraites et de tera mais
je pense que le mot rapide là j'ai
l'impression depuis qu'il est qu'il a
été nommé jean castex ils apprennent ils
n'arrêtent pas de prononcer le mot
rapide et ça c'est quand même assez
nouveau parce que si on regarde le
dossier des retraites on a fait tous aux
la rapidité je crois que le voile est
négocié un an et demi pour donner ce que
ça a donné ce cercle est la lenteur
n'est pas le gage de ta passage en
douceur donc tout ça pour dire que il va
en termes de rythme oui il va simplement
est pas un changement de rythme à
l'heure du coup j'ai un peu perdu votre
question excusez moi
alors est ce qu'il veut en mesure de
faire face au défi social et les
élections c'est sans doute oui ça veut
dire qu'il va voir leurs impressions
c'est le compliqué mais moi je suis
d'accord que j'ai entendu avant
c'est-à-dire quand même j'ai
l'impression qu'avec ce cette visite au
commissariat et quand il dit la
préservation de l'ordre républicain
n'est pas négociable c'est pas une
phrase ne
n'est pas négociable on veut négocier
beaucoup de choses mais pas la passion
de l'ordre républicain
je pense que s'adresse quand même à 7 ce
qu'on appelait autrefois la mine
majorité silencieuse
c'est à dire des gens qui quand même ont
été beaucoup choqué par par toute cette
agitation ces violences autour de quelle
que soit la cause que ce soit les jets
les jaunes la sphère traoré et c'est
donc la wii rentrée sociale négociations
mais on tolérera pas n'importe quoi dans
les rues c'est ce que j'entends ce que
vous entendez est ce que c'est ce que
vous entendez également alexis oui c'est
ce que je disais je crois qu'il prépare
justement là les troupes du ministère de
l'intérieur à revenir sur le devant de
la scène ils ont des années déjà
difficile mais plutôt que de traiter le
mal à la racine c'est-à-dire de lancer
le dialogue
il prépare déjà une réponse par la façon
dure par la répression des mouvements
sociaux
or il va falloir jouer sur les deux
tableaux parce que ça ne pourra pas
tenir longtemps avec la dette qui va
exploser avec le chômage qui va exploser
avec cette croissance qui ne dépend pas
que de les volontés des français on est
au niveau mondial dans un climat de
récession donc ça ne sert à rien de
taper sur les gens si ils sont
malheureux qu'ils ont peur du
déclassement au contraire il faut les
rassurer il faut organiser le moyen
d'éviter à tout prix ce déclassement
c'est ce que nous dit cet autre
internaute un fly 94 qui nous dit castex
ne pourra pas stoppé la troisième vague
sociale car quel que soit son action les
résultats n'arriveront pas tout de suite
olivier babeau sur ça effectivement les
la volonté en tous les cas de
réindustrialisation vous avez dit ça
passe ça prend du temps et
on s'attend tous à une rentrée
économique extrêmement sévère surtout
avec des chiffres et des chiffres
importants des chiffres énormes en
termes de récession oui attitude est
encore grande mais malheureusement le
pire scénario
ce n'est pas totalement improbable c'est
à dire une augmentation de 1,2 1,5
million de chômeurs tout d'un coup
quelque chose d'extrêmement brutal
c'est là que l'idée de relance pour le
coup le mot n'a jamais été aussi bien
trouver parce qu'il s'agit bien de
relancer une machine qui a été
complètement arrêté
je suis pas totalement sûr qu' une sorte
de troisième comment dire de troisième
vague sociale parce que justement face à
sète
c'est une amie de chômage ce
gouvernement il va je pense avoir un
petit peu les coudées franches en
matière budgétaire
on voit très bien que le thème n'est pas
l'économie la réforme de l'état donc
tout ça est mis complètement sous le
boisseau
alors il ya évidemment une incertitude 1
c'est celle des retraites
on peut se poser la question pourquoi
emmanuel macron déjà quelle éthique
faire dans cette galère mais alors quel
que j'ai un tigre faire dans cette
galère
la caisse qui vient à deux ans
c'est-à-dire il ya un an et sur la
question des retraites voilà voir dépend
de la façon dont ça va être était alors
jeu pour revenir sur le premier ministre
il coche quand même une bonne case qui
est celui d'élu local dam d'un patelin
qu'est donc pas trop grosse et fall pas
le havre est 7e à cette connaissance
profonde du terrain et aussi d'ailleurs
je crois cette capacité à connaître
aussi les les
les partenaires sociaux et négocier avec
eux fait vraiment partie de ce don de
mener m on a besoin depuis les gilet
jaune c'est à dire cette recréation des
corps intermédiaires et ce lien qui doit
être heureux tissés avec les territoires
de ce point de vue là jean castex
évidemment a le bon profil apparemment
calme avant de voir un petit peu quelles
doivent être les chantiers du
du nouveau gouvernement du futur
gouvernement dont on attend l'annoncé en
tout cas le remaniement qui est annoncé
à partir de 17h il est 17 heures 18 ans
on sait quelle était la position de jean
castex sur le sur le déconfinement
est-ce qu'il était favorable à un
déconfinement rapide plus rapide en tout
cas que edouard philippe
vous avez décidé d'enfoncer un coin
entre l'elysée et matignon là vincent je
vous pose des questions et vous
connaissez déjà la réponse est non de ce
qu'on sait c'est que jean castex était
aussi prudents que les douars philippe
sur la sortie du confinement
c'est emmanuel macron qui a poussé pour
que le déconfinement se fasse dès le 11
mai et c'est d'ailleurs cette partie là
qui a donné lieu où plus grande tension
entre l'elysée et matignon
au point qu'un proche de démêler le
maquereau on m'a parlé de deux
cohabitations pour décrire la période
des quelques jours qui ont précédé et
suivi ce moment là pourquoi parce que au
moment où il prépare le plan pour la
sortie du confinement
on est le 8,9 mais c'est prévu pour le
11 mai et on imagine que le conseil au
ciel va pouvoir siéger le dimanche
tranquillement et validé le plan est
évidemment pensé conçu l on dit bah non
nous on cherche pas le dimanche on va
siéger que lundi et donc on se retrouve
là avec un confinement qui va commencer
dans un vide juridique et donc
fatalement que dit matignon avec edouard
philippe et son directeur de cabinet
benoît ribadeau dumas qui sont tous les
deux issus du conseil d'état donc des
juristes et disent pas non pas de base
légale
il faut décaler la sortie du confinement
et l elysée on est peut-être visiblement
moins à cheval sur les règles juridiques
la question est totalement tranché en on
ne retarde pas et on y va
et donc là il ya eu un bras de fer et
dans ce bras de fer a on sait pas
exactement le rôle précis qu'a joué jean
castex parce que lui pour le coup ils
étaient là pour mettre en oeuvre le
le déconfinement mais ça me paraît assez
clair qu'il était plutôt quand même sur
la ligne de 2 des doors fils alors
justement jean baptiste audi on peut lui
reprocher tant qu'on pourra encore
discuter du bien fondé du confinement et
bien on continuera à voir qu'elle était
peut-être le saura-t-on dans quelques
peut-être vous avez des infos sylvie
c'est votre spécialité ça d'avoir des
infos sur sa qualité la position de jean
castex exactes sur le confinement
j'ai dit désolé je vais vous décevoir je
suis très très triste de vous décevoir
mais je ne sais pas dans votre prochain
portrait de jean castex
on se verra si on lira dans le journal
du dimanche ou dans vanity fair mais
dans les deux cas ce sera sûrement à
lire on vous posez donc la question les
premiers pas de jean castex en tant que
premier ministre vous ont-ils convaincu
et bien en pour l'instant ils ne vous
ont majoritairement pas convaincu mais
c'est assez partagés alors babineau a
répondu à notre question j'ai hâte de
connaître le nom du successeur de
castetner les regards sont tournés vers
le ministère de l'intérieur
c'est en tout cas effectivement l'une
des questions qu'on se pose ce soir sur
la personnalité du ministre de
l'intérieur et surtout le cap qui sera
donné à 7 ce ministère important ces
ministères règle